It seems like a smart thing to do first would be to go through and try and determine
what are the potential sources of error in this experiment.
Well, first, our whole experiment was based on the assumption that the earth is a sphere.
We also used the assumption that the sun's rays arrive at the earth parallel in different locations,
and we justified this by saying that the sun is so far away that its rays must be coming nearly parallel.
Next, we had the fact that the sun's rays were vertical in Syene.
We also had to measure the angle of the sun's rays in Alexandria. This is the angle that we called alpha.
And finally, we are to measure the distance between Syene and Alexandria.
Now, these are the five steps or assumptions that I identified for this problem.
There could be others that you may have identified,
but these are the ones that I think are most important.
If any of these were incorrect, so for example, if the earth wasn't really a sphere,
well that would throw off our entire geometry calculation.
Likewise, if the sun's rays didn't arrive exactly in parallel,
or if they weren't exactly vertical in Syene?
Any problem in any of these steps would of course lead to error, which would
propagate through our experiment and show up as an error in our circumference calculation.
Let's go through each of these potential sources of error
and quantify how much we think it may have contributed to the error of our final calculation.
Step 1, earth is a sphere. It turns out the earth isn't a perfect sphere.
It's actually what's known as an oblate spheroid, which is a much cooler name,
but all it means is that it's a little fatter around the middle.
It turns out that this difference is so, so tiny that this one really introduced any actual error
into our calculation barely even measurable, so I'm going to call
this potential source of error as negligible.
Next, we've seen that the sun's rays arrive parallel which means that the rays would strike Syene,
actually strike parallel to those striking Alexandria.
It turns out this is not exactly true. The rays are not perfectly parallel.
For a homework problem, you'll actually calculate how much error this will contribute
to our measurement of the circumference or to our calculation of the circumference.
But, I'll tell you for now that it's negligible.
Next, we had this idea that the sun's rays are arriving vertically in Syene.
Now, this seems like it could be a potential source of error.
Now, let's think of how Eratosthenes came to this conclusion
that the sun's rays were perfectly vertical in Syene on the summer solstice.